hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it's a home well other funds
last week in the comments made by the
director of my rap monster I've been
doing a little singing asking myself
some question like fuck about doing with
my wife just rumor I wanna be pathetic
loser so I do what I always do when I
get really depressed I want you'll
nostalgic TV uh sergeant slaughter you
represent a simpler time when your last
name could also represent illegal war
crimes or when your biggest problem was
not collecting the latest action set
fight the good fight sergeant slaughter
here we're gonna have to bake it at the
ride mutant ended battle by Oh Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle pies I remember when
the lime fresh from the steward actually
sounded appetizing from the story thingy
oh god is this the only thing to bring
me pleasure just pure patheticness
thousand I'm a rack oh there there
critic it's not so bad so bad get out of
here fine fine I'm a dinosaur
fucking commercials what is it about
them that draws me to them they're so
conniving and yet so inviting it's like
they're in their own little world a
world that wants to be nice to you but
scam you at the exact same time
something about them strangely gives me
comfort I can actually watch these ads
all day actually it's not a bad idea
maybe I need to take a break from
nostalgic movies and nostalgic TV shows
and take a look at the stuff in between
I mean I loved commercials growing up
that got me excited for all the things I
Bester my parents over until their ears
gushed with blood every time you watch
them you felt like you were making it
deal with them you buy their products
and then return to terior ate your
some physical health it's a good trade
how can such cunning manipulation go
unappreciated know what fucking I'm
gonna take this whole episode I'm just
gonna watch commercials yeah this is a
tribute to all the plastic sugar-coated
nonsense that we loved growing up this
is a segment I like to call after these
messages these messages messages I'm not
gonna go on any order or time together
with any theme it's just going to be
commercials commercials commercials so
let's get started
look different from me never back uh
Apple Jacks you remember these
commercials right it always starts off
with a group of kids eating the cereal
and some snooty know-it-all always ask
why they like eating if it doesn't taste
like apples just a good point why the
hell doesn't it taste like apples it's
like if cocoa puffs
tasted like old brand it's kind of false
advertising Jeff on from me never back
cool would be yes but we'll see if he's
cool by subjecting him to the Apple
Jacks test not the Apple tracks to is
the Apple Jacks twist demanded Apple
Jacks should it taste like apple red and
white tea so good in line
please choose choose wisely
baby pill you have chosen wise care
example Jack zero is part of the
complete record and then they all end
with the kids taking a picture together
but my absolute favorite is the caption
at the bottom Apple Jacks 94 somebody
actually looked at this picture and
called it Apple Jacks 94 as if to say
yeah I remember that summer that was the
summer of Apple Jacks the summer where
anything was possible the summer where
boys became men and girls became women
was Apple Jacks I know I wrote it on a
picture do you think the kids from it
did that like when they all took that
picture together they simply labeled it
the summer of Apple Jacks 54 you know
instead of the summer out oh my god I
kill a clown a fucking killer clown
don't ever forget the killer clown a
killer clown could happen kill example
Jack cereal is part of this complete
breakfast I don't know what she's eating
you really what we like about Popples
that was a clever idea there's a series
of sports balls that can be turned into
cuddly creatures
this raises a few questions though like
why were they playing with a furry
pillow like ball to begin with hey you
got our basketball oh wow that's a hairy
fucker it doesn't bounce in the
slightest this will do us well and then
of course when they go after the ball
well shit he's got a supernatural
creature that hasn't been discovered by
science yet but where's that darn ball
also I felt bad playing with these
because I always felt like I was giving
the Popples a migraine I mean you're
kicking them around throwing them
doesn't that hurt the Popples wouldn't
come out like this they look more like
this but oh well you can't fault it on
still being a clever product ok I don't
know what the fuck this kid is on but I
want kinds of cream inside
he likes giggles funny faces the sponge
of vanilla cream in each home god people
stoned out of their minds to laugh this
hard new giggles cookie
two kinds of cream in each funny face
are you gonna hear that turn the gas off
turn the gas off in some time in the
future this ad was unbelievable this is
like one of those fucking epic
commercials ever put on television the
ultimate Kalen
okay it's set in this apocalyptic future
where the fate of the world rests in the
hands of two kids who sit at a table for
marbles at even bigger marbles
it's like the world of Tron if it was
run by Lucas it's the most badass
commercial ever
don't be afraid to bother getting your
my
Santa has a very special Christmas
message he wants everyone to hear I
don't think they do these anymore but a
long long time ago they used to have
hotlines for everything call one nine
hundred ninety-nine for three hundred
two dollars Firstman at forty five cents
each additional look at that just two
dollars for the first minute and only
forty five cents every additional minute
it's pretty fucking costly for the 1980s
and santa needs your help to spread the
Christmas cheer via Santa's helper I
always remember you call him up in some
jerk off what talk as slowly as possible
so he could make sure that he eats up
your time and your fucking money
what a dick cock get your parents
permission to call Santa special phone
number now actually this sort of takes
on a different meaning nowadays doesn't
it when you make a call that cost money
there's usually a different idea behind
it and the idea of being a part of that
is pretty freakin creepy
speaking of Santa only if you get
nostalgic whenever you see this
commercial over here it's practically a
staple of Christmas now
yabba-dabba-do did is just do oh ho ho
ho hungry Santa
babbles your pebbles tis the season to
be sharing Fred
happy holidays poor food hey Fred how
can we celebrate Christmas if Jesus is
in Borneo just ate your fuckin cereal
get this when Nintendo was all the rage
they actually made a Nintendo cereal
yeah wasn't a Mario cereal or Zelda
cereal it was just Nintendo and Jack
what a weird idea it's kind of like
making Internet the cereal isn't it
though it would probably be the first
seria where you have to be over 18 to
eat it and it wasn't just call Nintendo
cereal it was called the Nintendo cereal
system what the hell does that do you
really have to put the word system at
the end are we really gonna confuse this
Nintendo for another Nintendo okay
you're here you can make a beautiful
party make a cute baby
no you meant Nintendo the entertainment
system I thought you meant Nintendo the
animatronic horse that only eats
toothpaste and circus midgets
he's very big in Sweden it was kind of
cool because it was technically two
cereals in one that means there were two
bags in each box
I remember it was kind of a pain once
you open the bag you can't really close
it so if you open both of them and
poured it out you'll get double the
cereal all over the place maybe that's
why it didn't last so long because half
of it was on the floor instead of a bowl
well if I had Nintendo on it you know we
were gonna love it anyway
Wow just like today fast food joints
handed out toys with their kids meals
and sometimes you get a cup like these
he-man ones here at Burger King they
always told epic stories or at least as
much as they could being on a god but
here's my favorite part of this
commercial the kids get the cops and
what do they do use them as swords man
those must be some pretty ghetto kids I
mean was a stick really too expensive to
use as a sword so you have to use these
were these your birthday gifts right
after they took you to your party at the
dollar store
hardcore kids really hardcore
guys there's work to do next move I
don't know what these kids problem is
but he cracks me up listen to him he's
taking funtime just a little too
frigging seriously calm down kid you're
building sand castles and Lincoln Logs
you're not a contracting construction
worker why are these kids even hang out
with them all he's doing is yelling at
him all day it's like in junior Sam
Kinison
a wife and kids with your eyes bigger
than drugs power makes the crane and
hardhats
each sold separately batteries not
included you from Revell hell yeah
transformers these were the coolest toys
out there even if they didn't take an
hour to figure out how the fuck they
worked they were still awesome and we
loved every minute the coolest one of
these commercials was the insecticons
the robots that look like insects
why because goddamn it I like to think
Tom Hanks influenced something in the
movie big yeah we heard his idea we
thought it was awesome and a kid asked
to suddenly see these things around
something that used to be in every
transformer commercial was an awesome
but kind of creepy moment when the kids
would say the robots in disguise line
sizes
I mean it's cool but it's also pretty
freaky it's like the kid got possessed
by the devil or something your mother
have to come check me out yeah I can't
go wrong with this game and the song it
turns out was pretty catchy too if you
haven't played this game then you have
no childhood this game was entertaining
then and it's still entertaining now if
you're waiting for the dentist and they
have another little toy basket but still
cops kind of a lame joke they would do
is that they would find as many puns
they could do with the word for
fortissimo yeah those were good but
let's see how far we can really push it
real old-school candles away what else
can you say but solid game with a salad
and connect for from Milton Bradley
behold the most boring thing in the
entire friggin world I was fascinated by
kids who had chia pet you know how they
say something is so boring that they'd
rather watch grass grow
well nothing me the toy out of it they
made a toy out of watching grass grow
that's how bored apparently we got and
just look at this incredible selection
they have thea teddy bears puppies
kittens rams hold there's even a chia
tree tree they actually put a tree in
there it's already a fucking tree does
nothing except grow that's all a tree
does tickity a chia pet the buttery that
grows if you liked it good for you but
don't be surprised if you have a sudden
fascination with chia paint dry and for
the love of God don't invite your
friends over to watch you will be pinned
Padilla buh buh buh bullshit this is
micro machine mantas anymore this guy is
awesome he started off as the FedEx man
and moved on to a toy called micro
machine which simply I don't think
exists
Kuzya mini micro machine vehicles planes
opposed to the police station the marina
the mini motorcycle repair shop the gas
station the construction office port the
real working drawbridge highway
passenger wrap and grog door this guy is
an advertiser's dream come true he gets
out all the information you
in seconds literally seconds the
dramatically details birth we trim
replica of the real thing that hoes 25
micro machines with fabulous fantastic
features - totally terrific elevate his
real working hoist runway into cargo
arms every time he came on TV you felt
like you were doing ecstasy everything
just seems so fast and everything else
moved in slow-mo after he was done and
these play sets fit together to form a
precise micro machine world boom its
mother calm to din the micro scene man
here ever carry there you can't have
this thank god this guy doesn't do audio
books to be or not to be that is the
question whether tis nobler in the mind
to suffer the slings and arrows of
outrageous fortune or to take arms
against a sea of troubles and by
opposing end to die to Sleep No More and
by a sleep to say we end the heartache
and the thousand natural shocks that
flesh is heir to tis a consummation
devoutly to be wished to die just leap
to sleep perchance to dream
aye there's the rub for in that sleep of
death what dreams may come the toys were
awesome and this guy was awesome
let's hope they both make a comeback
sometime soon remember if it doesn't say
micromachines it's not the real thing
speaking of Awesome why the hell is
there no more ecto cooler in the world
this was like the coolest drink ever and
by god is the only good thing that's not
bubble Slimer ever produced I XI and X
liners make you drink those speaking of
which what are we supposed to assume
that stuff is I mean did the best thing
to come out a Slimer and literally come
out of Slimer oh my god we could be
drinking slime or splooge he already to
her looks like a giant sperm it's like
the sperm of a sperm are dude I don't
wanna think about it bastard
whatever it was it was incredible and
lasted a real long time but at some
point they discontinued it and by Ghawar
we pissed off
I keep hearing they're gonna make a new
Ghostbusters movie sometime soon and I'm
telling you right now if they do not do
a crossover with Ghostbusters 3 and
break ecto cooler back somebody really
will be a fucking ghost and too cool
here's wet banana you can bath and flats
on wet banana like Billy yes be like
billion take a ride on the wet banana
happen look like ready yes dipping and
sliding is a very good thing to do with
your weapon M quickly what fun ball game
a very special kind of gang but yes
liberate wet fun is guaranteed could
that be maman web banana mom get off my
wet banana Oh dad say like your wet
banana 25 feet long and the new wet
banana do provide 30 feet long
my my that's a fucking big banana you
know typical cookie caution may hurt
some women down at Fraggle Rock yeah
Raghava the why'd you turn it off Chris
why don't you read something but the
Fraggles are really fun
ah yes the TV that actually encourages
you to read that's something you don't
see very often I'm so confident you
won't stop watching me that I'm just
giving you books ah ha ha ha you can't
read your addiction of me I will die in
- the Internet's invented I got 10 more
years suckas ha ha ha ha ha Oh God not
one of these when while you're here
commercial you might be able to sell it
if you stop now oh nasty I'm a dog oh
it's fun to help magic potty baby learn
to use her potty no it's not it's
fucking gross God and they say boys can
be disgusting ok you'll know words bet
Patti baby in her magic potty no water
no mess spray that thing doesn't have to
go number two there I spent all my time
watching no nostalgic movies and no
nostalgic TV shows just commercials
nothing but commercials oh my god is
even more pathetic well I spent all my
time watching this shit that people skip
with me yeah this isn't life this is
make-believe I put sag on that a lot of
look at you you had such dreams ahead of
you such promise you were perfect back
then okay yeah birth control glasses
teeth like a chipmunk in a Dumb and
Dumber Erica that only got done a dumber
but you had such hope there's nothing
left for me
I am a loser you were right director of
my pet monster I'm a loser a weak
pathetic
loser
but I never intended all this bullshit
never and nobody really understood well
how could they
that all I ever wanted was to bring them
something great why does nothing ever
turn out like it should
well what la hack I went and did my best
and my god I really tasted something
swell for moment why I made the winters
cry and at least I told them they could
go to hell I did and for the first time
since I don't remember when I don't just
like my critical self again
and I know stash your fridge week that's
right the nostalgia critic and I just
can't wait until my next review
cuz I've got some new ideas that I
really want to do and by god I'm really
going to give it all my might
oh oh I hope there's still time to set
things right
Sandy Claws
Santa Claus I don't want say Santy Claus
I want to do another review
I don't know Jesus what do you think let
him rot okay well folks I'm back I may
be pathetic but I'm proud so welcome
back to the traditional nostalgia critic
where everything is back to normal
oh except Christmas may be gone forever
I
could that be maman web banana